let's see if we could give ourselves
some practice evaluating expressions
that have two different variables in
them so let's see if we can evaluate the
expression 7j + 5 - 8 k when j is equal
to 0.5 and k is equal to 0.25 so why
don't you try to pause the video and
evaluate this first before we work
through it together alright so if we
want to evaluate this thing everywhere
where we see a J we want to replace it
with a 0.5 and everywhere we see a K we
want to replace it with a 0.25 so let's
do that this is going to be seven times
and instead of J I'm going to put a zero
zero point five in there and then we
have plus five minus eight times K and K
we're saying is 0.25 0.25 so what is
this going to be equal to so if I were
to take if I were to take and I look I
can color-code this seven times zero
point five half of seven that's going to
be three and a half three point five
then I have plus five and then I'm going
to subtract I am subtracting eight times
0.25 0.25 this is 1/4 I could rewrite
this if I want 0.25 that's the same
thing as 1/4 eight times 1/4 or another
way to think about it is eight divided
by four is going to be equal to two so
this whole thing over here is going to
be equal to two so it's going to be
minus we have this minus out here so
minus two and what is this going to be
well let's think about it three point
five plus five is eight point five minus
two is going to be six point five so
this is equal to this is equal to six
point five let's do another one of these
all right
and we'll just like before try to work
through it on your own before before we
do it together all right now let's do it
together
so over here I have this expression 0.1
m plus 8 minus 12 n when M is equal to
30 and n is equal to 1/4
all right so everywhere every
Ric nm I want to replace with a 30 and
everywhere I see an N I want to replace
with the 1/4 so this is going to be
equal to 0.1 times M M is 30 times 30
plus 8 minus 12 times n where n is 1/4
and is 1/4 so what is what is 1/10 this
right over here is 0.1 that's the same
thing as 1/10 of 30
well 1/10 of 30 that's going to be 3 so
this part is 3 then 3 plus 8 and then
we're going to have - well what is 12
times 1/4 that's going to be 12 fourths
or 12 divided by 4 which is going to be
equal to 3 and now when we evaluate this
so that is equal to this we have a 3
plus 8 minus 3 well threes are going to
do a positive 3 and then you're going to
subtract 3 and you're just going to be
left with you're just going to be left
with an 8 and you're done this
expression when M is equal to 30 and N
is equal to 1/4 is equal to 8